over the past year the West has
Unleashed a far-reaching package of
sanctions that it hopes will
Russia's War Machine this includes
freezing the Russian Central bank's
access to hundreds of billions of
dollars in foreign currency reserves
Russian Banks and while the individuals
have had their assets Frozen and trade
with the country has been dramatically
cut the G7 and the EU also recently
introduced a price cap on Russian crude
oil which it hopes will drive down
market prices squeezing the country's
revenues
foreign
Russia's economy has coped fairly well
the EU delayed its ban on Russian oil
exports and in the meantime the country
benefited from soaring wholesale Energy
prices since then it has successfully
diverted much of its trade to China and
India
for people living in Russia unemployment
is at a record low and wage growth a
record high that being said hundreds of
thousands of people have left the
country and this loss of human capital
could soon start Weighing on economic
growth
foreign
s on Russia have not yet had the effect
that many Western leaders hoped but
things could soon start to change now
that the EU and the G7 have introduced
their price cap on Russian energy
exports the country's revenues are
falling just as military expenditure is
increasing it means the country is
having to sell Chinese currency reserves
in order to stabilize its finances
2023 will be more challenging for Russia
the country's energy revenues are
starting to fall but the country has
built up a significant cushion that
economists believe will allow it to
weather the strain of sanctions in the
coming year